chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
la question orale de Monsieur
Jean-François Humbert à monsieur le
ministre chargé des transports de la mer
et de la
Pêche monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers
collègues je souhaiteis en effet attiré
l'attention du ministre des Transports
mais je vous remercie madame la ministre
de bien vouloir répondre parce qu'il
doit être lui aussi en Afrique du
Sud
le sujet qui me préoccupe et le devenir
de la LGV Rin
rô pour laquelle le rapport durons sur
les grands
projets ferroviaires et
routiers qui été soumis au gouvernement
en juin 2013 communique de nombreuses
informations et en particulier une
information qui nous préoccupe
qui et l'information selon laquelle la
deuxè phase de cette ligne n'est plus
jugé comme prioritaire ce qui remet en
cause fortement la poursuite du
projet les 50
km qui sont encore à réaliser sont
reporté
après 2030 alors que il devait entrer en
service initialement en
2016 autant dire que le report à en 2030
euh donne une information selon laquelle
le projet est quasiment
abandonné je souhaite rappeler que ce
projet de TGV rinrô s'inscrit dans un
schéma européen de liaison rapide entre
l'Allemagne au nord et l'Espagne au
sud
le premier tronçon d'une longueur de 140
km est entré en service commercial en
descemb
le 11 décembre
2011 pour un budget de 2,6 milliards
d'euros et il reste à réaliser la
deuxième tranche vers Dijon à l'ouest de
l'ouvrage et vers mulouse à l'est à plus
long terme bien sûr il s'agira de
déterminer le tracé et de réaliser les
études et bien sûr de financer les
branches sud et ouest de
l'ourvrage l'origine comme une étoile à
trois
branches même si l'état réexamine
l'ensemble des grands projets
d'infrastructure annoncé lors du Grenel
de
l'environnement je vous demande madame
la ministre de bien vouloir m'indiquer
s'il est dans les intentions du
Gouvernement de poursuivre ce projet de
LGV r rô ou tout simplement de
l'abandonner
alors que l'État et les collectivités
territoriales ont signé un protocole
d'accord en 2012 en vue d'achever la
deuxième tranche du projet je vous
remercie de votre réponse madame la
ministre merci chers collègues la parole
est à Madame Dominique pertinotti
ministre chargé de la
famille monsieur le sénateur vous l'avez
dit très justement monsieur cuviler est
également effectivement avec monsieur le
Président de la République en Afrique du
Sud
et je me permets de de vous adresser la
la la réponse qu'il souhaite vous
apporter les différentes composantes de
la LGV rinrô sur chacune de ces trois
branches ne sont pas au même stade
d'avancement la section la plus
importante de la branche Est a été mise
en service fin 2011 et ces deux
extrémités vers Dijon et mulouse ont
fait l'objet d'étude approfondie qui
conduisent un investissement
supplémentaire de plus d'un milliards
d'euros sur les branches ouest et sud
les études sont nettement moins avancées
et les tracés ne sont pas encore définis
les premières estimations donnent
toutefois une idée de l'ampleur des
investissements à prévoir qui se situe
pour ces deux branches autour de 8
milliards d'euros dans le cadre de la
mission que lui a confié le gouvernement
la commission mobilité 21 a présenté des
propositions visant à préciser les
conditions de mise en œuvre du schéma
national des infrastructures de
transport pour le rendre compatible avec
la situation et les perspective des
finances publiques pour le projet de
ligne à grande vitesse rinrô la
commission l'a classé en 2è priorité et
a proposé comme vous l'avez dit de
poursuivre sa réalisation à comptter de
2030 c'est d'ailleurs la recommandation
faite par la commission pour tous les
nouveaux projets de de ligne à grande
vitesse is le projet de ligne reliant
Bordeaux à Toulouse le gouvernement a
décidé de suivre ses recommandations
tout en précisant que la priorisation
des projets devrait être revue dans 5
ans et que 2030 constitue un horizon de
temps qui pouvait être raccourci en
fonction des ressources financières
disponibles du coût et de la maturité
des projets pour les C prochaines années
la priorité a été donné par le
gouvernement à l'amélioration des
transports du quotidien il s'agit pour
cela d'accélérer la résorption des nœuds
ferroviaires de moderniser les lignes de
chemin de fer classique et de
désenclaver les territoires ainsi en
Franche compté il apparaît primordial
d'aménager le réseau existant pour le
rendre plus performant et répondre aux
besoins régulièrement exprimés par les
usagers sur la qualité du service à
travers la sécurité la régularité
l'efficacité des correspondances ou
encore le confort du matériel roulant le
Premier ministre a lancé en septembre la
nouvelle contractualisation État-Région
et a demandé que son volet mobilité soit
finalisé d'ici la fin de l'année il
s'agit de définir en concertation les
opérations prioritaires à réaliser dans
les prochaines années en terme
d'infrastructure en outre le grand plan
de modernisation du réseau demandé par
Frédéric hviler à réseau ferréde France
va être décliné territorialement dans
les prochaines semaines merci Monsieur
Humbert merci madame la ministre pour
votre
réponse qui n'est pas très satisfaisante
mais c'est pas à vous que je le reproche
c'est au ministre des Transports que
j'aurai l'occasion lors d'une prochaine
séance de question et en l'absence d'un
déplacement que je comprends il pourra
me répondre plus précisément sur non pas
l'ensemble de la réalisation de ce qui
reste à faire pour la ligne LGV
elle-même branche
sud branche ouest mais simplement
répondre sur la manière dont il conçoit
avant 2030 de financer la fin de la
tranche Dijon mulouse il reste 50 km à
faire ça n'est pas énorme et c'est
là-dessus que j'aurais souhaité une
réponse plus complète mais néanmoins
merci pour votre réponse même si elle
est pour moi incomplète merci merci
chers collègues je vais donc suspendre
la séance elle sera reprise à 17h